ils étaient prêts à avancer sociaux de
rage entre minsk et la juste je sais que
vous êtes proches du policier qui a été
lynché samedi dernier à la marche des
libertés sa danse est inadmissible
il ya eu il ya eu beaucoup moindre
aversion nous soit dit c'est
inadmissible
oui c'est quoi cette ville le mot est
faible pour le poste oui c'est vrai oui
faible coût qui et comment vous avez
réagi qu'est-ce que vous êtes dit vous
les proches de ceux proches de ce
policier qui a été lent chez moi j'ai eu
au téléphone dimanche il avait forcément
un peu de mal à parler parce qu'il a il
a quatre dents en moins
il avait énormément de douleur parce
qu'il a l'impression d'être passé dans
une lessiveuse forcément c'est ce qui
arrive quand on se fait prendre à partie
comme sa parole par une dizaine
d'individus
mais au delà de ça c'est un
fonctionnaire qu'à 50 police n'a pas non
plus énormément d'expérience et je pense
qu'il sera marquée à vie parce que
évidemment alors dire ça quand ça peut
être compliqué ce qui est arrivé c'est
admissible mais à venir permission il
espérait la seule chose qu'il espérait
c'est justement ne pas perdre
connaissance
parce qu'ils avaient peur quand on
arrive dans cette situation là on est
totalement perdu et il est isolé on sait
pas où sont nos collègues et la seule
chose avec ali pensais c'était justement
de passer va nourrir et donc non il a
été sorti après mais il m'a
littéralement 10 réceptions ces mots je
me suis vu mourir
donc il a pensé à arrêter non non parce
que parce que non enfin j'y cours moi je
crois forcément même à la nouvelle
génération policiers même si en effet on
a des problèmes de formation ou en tout
cas on doit l'améliorer c'est une
évidence et il ya plein de choses à
améliorer et nous on se bat pour ça
c'est pour les conditions de travail je
trouve que le ministre et vous savez
qu'on n'est pas toujours tendre avec
avec politique je trouve que le ministre
pour une fois a eu un mot très juste
c'est que lors de la commission des lois
à l'assemblée il a dit on devrait
commencer par s'excuser pour les
conditions dans laquelle on envoie les
policiers sur le terrain je trouve que
là c'est l'essentiel
hmmm ça rejoint ce que vous mêmes faits
c'était
jim qui est devenu mise à l'intérieur et
qui ne donnait pas les moyens allergique
est le premier point se touche de
l'émission je pense que les français ont
répondu aux études de l'émission les
français ont confiance dans leur police
ils ont confiance dans leur programme
nord ils ont confiance dans l'armée ils
ont confiance lumière juin dans leur
service public qui est le dit de façon
massive majoritaire toutes les classes
d'âge sont concernées cette façon
constante nous emm éléments c'est ce que
disait agathe et c'est un peu dérangeant
et sk une impunité structure a dans la
foulée ciment un sentiment d'impunité
j'attends ça vous garantir que tous les
policiers auxquels on parle auquel je
parle en direct
il se sent pas du tout le sentiment
d'impunité aux consciences et se sont
aussi à des pôles montre le direct la
verte un et certains prise inverse
contrôler en permanence je savais que
par ailleurs je veux dire être policier
en 2020 c'est pas être policier dans les
années 80 aujourd'hui
dans les années 80 vous étiez plutôt
fier d'avoir un papa policier
aujourd'hui que vous cachez plus tôt
vous avez des policiers qui sont sans
arrêt comme il ya surveillés par des
sites comme paul ce qu'on suit passion
et c'est le souhait des vidéos et je le
dit d'un mot et c'est évidemment
insupportable d'avoir quel que soit
d'ailleurs les français qu'ils soient
forces de l'ordre fonctionnaires ou
france elle est suivie d identifier et
qu'on appelle à des lynchages publics au
travers des réseaux sociaux c'est
insupportable c'est vrai un supporter
tout le monde un mot sur la vidéo et je
finis sur les manifestations pour dire
deux choses d'abord vous avez raison
qu'il faut pouvoir filmer librement en
france il faut que les journalistes
puissent faire librement leur travail
il est policier de moi aussi ils veulent
les caméras piétons y compris pour se
protéger il comprit pouvoir remettre du
contexte et pouvoir mieux se défendre et
pourra dire que quand parfois
effectivement les choses se passent qui
puisse expliquer le pourquoi du comment
ministre alors voilà comment vous pouvez
nous enlever nous manifestons de nous
protéger par la vidéo
c'était pas ça s'est passé la semaine
dernière vous voulez que je vous montre
l'état de mon téléphone jusqu'à ce que
monsieur passamainty bâton dessus je dis
des mots fusent et moi mais moi je
je n'ai rien à faire avec mon téléphone
je fais quoi je filme les manifestations
que j'organise qu'est ce que je vous
fais de mal avec mon téléphone je le
disais nous apprennent général je parle
en général
vous m'avez vous jeudi dernier après je
pose une question l'article 24 dont il
est question c'est est pas du tout un
article qui interdit de filmer
l'article 24 bis oui ça a été ça
monsieur j'étais parlementaire par les
parlementaires sur la loi les choses
évoluent et 10 il a toujours dit une
seule chose dans son esprit il a dit il
n'est pas permis de diffuser des images
en identifiant les gens est en jeu c'est
le penalty
la destination du film parce que ces
problèmes de votre l'homme est
heureusement vous avez osé enlever cet
article pour l'instant je sais que vous
préparez un article 25 de la prochaine
loi darmanin la sueur et renforcement
des principes républicains oui à la même
chose
la bataille n'est pas finie mais ce
n'est pas vrai ce que vous dites dans la
mesure où comme dans le cas des outrages
comme dans le cas de riz ou non il y
avait un délit dans de diffusion eh bien
ça fait des mois que vous n'hésitez pas
à dire moi je t'ai en baisse et pour
abolition de la liberté j'ai juste une
question laquelle et je finis toujours
par y apprendre à lancer une parler des
manifestations
honnêtement les images qu'on a vu
interroger si la société les
manifestations et encore quelques années
c'était beaucoup de manifestants et pas
beaucoup de violence
aujourd'hui c'est peu de manifestants
est systématiquement des violences en
fin de cortège s'est interrogé par
l'insee qui vous leur premier magistrat
kebab à damas avaient toutes les
violences au monde à nab et toutes les
besoins sont là la question enfin moi ce
qui m'a beaucoup choqué mais c'est une
question de société gpg pas la réponse à
ça quand on voit sur une image un
policier par terre lynché par trois
black book avec trois personnes à venir
des journalistes caf qui filme tout
simplement simplement simplement c'est
une question de société quand je dit un
policier
c'est à dire 3 black block qui le lynche
au sol et trois personnes qui filme
sincèrement ça interroge sur la société
dans laquelle on vit
moi j'ai pas la réponse à ça j'ai
quelques idées quand même sur la façon
de n'arriver à pacifier tout ça mais ça
devrait nous interrogeait le vrai sujet
c'est comment on arrive là en 2020 il ya
plein de raisons les réseaux sociaux la
grande des inhibitions une re a finalisé
la goffe fait deux ans que ça dure hélas
montrer non excusez moi faisons des
dizaines de la marge est libre c'est un
mouvement l'argent vous avez laissé ce
film est que les gens viennent avec des
matins qui casserait seulement quatrième
fois un magasin que la réalité y en a
qui veulent empêcher les gens de films
et bien ça c'est pas normal
évaluation moi je sais pas d'où venait
du réel chez logic